tu vas le gouvernement a annoncé des
mesures pour apaiser les tensions
l'entrée des aliments et des médicaments
sur l'île est désormais autorisée sans
limite de valeur et sans taxes
douanières elles c'était l'une des
revendications de la population les
cubains sont confrontés à des fortes
pénuries aggravée par la crise
économique
pour en parler nous sommes avec meriem
laribi suis journaliste pour le site de
rt france
bonjour meriem laribi merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france dont quels
sont les éléments déclencheurs à de ces
manifestations
bonjour cuba traverse une importante
crise économique comme vous l'avait dit
il ya d'importantes files d'attentes
pour s'approvisionner en nourriture
d'une pénurie de médicaments de matériel
médical des pannes d'électricité
tout cela a entraîné un fort malaise
social et a poussé un certain nombre de
cubains à descendre dans la rue pour
protester
cette crise économique importante est
due à la fois à l'épidémie de
coronavirus comme dans de nombreux
autres pays et il y a la difficulté pour
le gouvernement cubain de réussir des
réformes face à l'embargo des états unis
sur l'économie cubaine qui dure depuis
1952 62 pardon donc il y as d'un côté
l'épidémie qui a entraîné un arrêt
brutal du tourisme l'une des principales
sources de revenus de l'île entraînant
un fort manque à gagner et face à cela
et bien le gouvernement cubain a très
peu de marges de manoeuvre étant donné
l'embargo total imposé par washington
depuis près de 60 ans vous savez que
l'extra territorialité des lois
américaines permet à washington
d'imposer d'interdire à n'importe quelle
entreprise à travers le monde de
commercer avec cuba
le gouvernement cubain d'ailleurs
qualifié cet embargo de blocus et on a
vu récemment
l'assemblée générale des nations unies a
voté pour la 29e fois une résolution à
une écrasante majorité
condamnant l'embargo des états unis sur
cuba 184 pays ont voté pour cette
résolution de pays ont voté contre les
états unis et israël et trois pays se
sont abstenus
le brésil l'ukraine et la colombie vous
parliez justement à l'instant de la
colombie vous avez écrit un article
comparant la réaction des états unis
dans la récente crise en colombie et
celle actuelle de cuba est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un petit peu plus à
ce sujet oui c'était intéressant
d'observer la différence de réaction de
washington face à deux crises donc
récentes qui ont eu lieu dans deux pays
d'amérique latine
la colombie en mai et cuba il y a
quelques jours donc en colombie vous
vous en souvenez en mai il ya eu
d'importantes d'énormes manifestations
avec des centaines de milliers de
personnes dans la rue durant plusieurs
semaines et le gouvernement colombien
qui est un allié de washington
gouvernement de droite libérale a
férocement réprimé la pole les
manifestants entraînant la mort de 42
personnes et plus de 2000 blessés
il a alors fallu attendre huit jours
pour que washington publie un premier et
unique communiqué dans lequel il
appelait à la modération mais tout en
exprimant un soutien sans faille à la
colombie 10 22 août à cuba en revanche
après de premières manifestations certes
depuis de nombreuses années il n'y avait
pas eu de manifestations à cuba mais il
a fallu à peine quelques heures pour que
washington publie une pluie de
communiquer hostiles au gouvernement
cubain
nous avons le président joseph biden lui
même et le secrétaire d'état anthony
bling qui tous les deux n'avaient pas
pipé mot sur ce qui se passait en
colombie eh bien ils ont immédiatement
réagi concernant cuba et ils ont qu'ils
ont tous les suisses ont tous les deux
exprimé pour soutenir les manifestants
les manifestants contre le gouvernement
à cuba donc il a fallu huit jours pour
la colombie
répète et moins de huit heures away pour
à washington pour s'exprimer concernant
ce qui se passait à cuba vous pourrez
d'ailleurs à cet égard facilement adapté
l'adage de jean de la fontaine et dire
selon que vous serez libéral ou
socialiste les jugements de washington
vous rendront blanc ou noir
l'un deux poids deux mesures et des
dents qui trouve ses racines dans la
doctrine monroe dont on raconte
l'histoire dans notre article
joseph byden qui avait assuré que
l'amérique était de retour et qu'il
allait rompre avec la politique de
donald trump ne fait en fait que
poursuivre la stratégie des états unis
d'ingérence et de domination en tout cas
sur l'amérique latine
merci beaucoup mais il m'est arrivé
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste pour
le site web d'arte et france